hey guys my name is jeff mcdonald it is
the 23rd of gene today and you're
joining me again big game spot news also
it's Monday let's talk about video games
phil spencer is mercied his way back in
time several centuries in phrasing by
telling games industry international but
he tips his metaphorical hat for Sony
successful ps4 launch the Xbox head
stressed this does not spell peril to
the Xbox one explaining maybe we're ten
percent of the way into this generation
so we're early early days in our this
will all play out I tip my hat to them
he went on to say that this is a
long-term competitive space which is
good for consumers Spencer also
reiterated that the removal of the
kinect for the system bundle does not
mean that they're any less enthusiastic
about the technology Spencer said
consumers love the device they love the
experience they'll buy it so either bide
launch when they buy their console or
they'll be able to buy it after the 399
console they'll pick it up and add it on
later and we'll continue to make sure
that experience is great when it comes
to virtual reality though Spencer said
he isn't so sure that the technology
will have mainstream appeal just yet so
it's probably unlikely that we'll see
that sort of thing from Microsoft any
time in the near future spoiler haters
beware because the witcher 3 wild hunt
has had a bunch of storing info and
other bits and pieces leaked onto the
internet will keep this segment spoiler
free though so not to worry a series of
screen shots featuring concept art and
various design and development details
hit reddit and according to gaming site
jill shoppers the documents reveal 64
monsters and 174 music tracks CD Projekt
RED have issued a statement about the
leaked files saying a portion of the
files contains information about the
story of the game so we strongly advise
against accessing them as this may
heavily impact and spoil
your future gaming experience the
documents were apparently obtained by
somebody who hacked into a Google Drive
belonging to one of the devs not a real
good advocate will drive there a bunch
of people have noticed that battlefield
hardline looks an awful lot like
battlefield 4 so the developer visceral
games have come out to say why hardline
is more than just an expansion lead
multiplayer designer that'sthat's at old
playstation lifestyle that it's the way
in which they using the Frostbite 3
engine which will make it feel brand new
specifically he said we improve the
vehicle physics and so on because in the
cops and criminal setting vehicle
collisions are way more important than
in battlefield he also said there's no
recycling of assets from battlefield 4
and they're going to have a wide range
of maps more weapons gadgets and a slew
of new game modes let me know if you
reckon hardline is gonna pull something
new out of the back or if you're just
expecting same old battlefield that is
it for me today and all the good news he
things but i'll be back same time and
place tomorrow so i'll be sure to catch
a bit